welcome to thick boy fighters let's dive
in
luke rockhold's former rival michael
bisping took the time to put their
heated history aside and congratulate
rockhold on his retirement on his
youtube channel bisping spoke about
rockhold's storied career and the
courage it took to return to the octagon
i wish you all the best in retirement
luke i really really do mean that i know
we've had some back and forths over the
years but it was just competitive just
rivals sporting rivals i'm sure if we
met under different circumstances in
fact i always said this i'm sure we'd
get along we've got some mutual friends
and jason pirillo thinks the world of
you as well so congratulations in what
you do luke i do believe is
underappreciated by a lot of people the
run that he had the career that he had
strike force champion ufc champion
always a top contender always in big
fights always took on the best
challenges to go out there and lose
three of your last four all by knockout
to then go and take three years away
from the sport and come back and go
right in co-main event in a pay-per-view
against paulo costa an absolute killer
that tells you the measure of the man
that tells you what the man is made of
and what he thinks of himself and the
kind of challenges and risks he's
willing to take
jorge masvidal has been vocal about
wanting to challenge leon edwards for
his newly acquired welterweight title
but has been on the receiving end the
pushback due to his three-fight losing
streak now leon edwards coach dave
lavelle is responding in a recent
interview with mma junkie lavelle had
some scathing words for mosvidal but
didn't rule out a potential fight leon
has been climbing the hill for a long
time as you know and he's tried to reach
the top and he's been knocked back
knocked back knocked back but now he's
climbed to the top he can be the one at
the top of the mountain knocking back
people well you can stand at the back of
the line mr mosvidal for starters mr
mosvidal you little rat judas your time
will come but also we'll pick it on our
terms the same way you told leon wait at
the back of the line well wait now mate
because leon's on the top of the hill
on episode 282 of the weighing in
podcast with josh thompson and big john
mccarthy the pair discussed the state of
the welterweight division after kamara
usman's shocking loss to leon edwards
big jon warned usman about his comments
that he is looking to get back in the
octagon as soon as before the new year
camaro uzman deserves
a rematch
against
leon edwards he deserves that based upon
what he's done so far as the
welterweight champion the run that he
was on
i did see where he said you know he was
he was thinking about trying to get
another fight in here before the end of
the year i'm like
stop
is that do people not manage their
fighters
you know
like the reason i said that fight should
take place somewhere around
you know march or so of
2023 was to give camaro time to recover
josh we we have too many people
that watch someone get knocked out like
he got knocked out
and because he was standing up at the
end and talking and everything he's okay
he's not okay
you know if if rocky had broken camaro's
leg
with a kick
and camaro crashed down with his leg
broken people would be going oh my god
it's horrible that's not as bad as what
happened to his brain
and so all i'm saying is camaro please
take some time off
march april perfect time don't try to
rush it into the januaries and february
march april perfect time that's when you
should be getting a rematch
does he deserve it yes his day has
already said
you yeah makes perfect sense yes
i said the o2 that all of a sudden it
was wembley stadium
i would love to see that thing at
wembley stadium
it would be
phenomenal if anyone's ever been to
wembley which you and i have
it is a freakishly large
stadium very cool and to think that they
would hold a ufc
at a title event there
the only question is now coming back to
when do you hold the fight
it happens to rain in england all the
time a lot one championships friday
fight card one on prime video one will
be their debut on amazon prime video and
will feature one of their biggest
prospects in the heavyweight division
marcus almeida almeida is a jiu jitsu
world champion and adcc gold medalist
who recently transitioned to mma the
transition is going well as the
brazilian has amassed a 3-0 record and
will now see himself opposite of former
interim title challenger kirill
grishenko almeida has finished all three
of his mma fights in the first round and
recently spoke with grappling insider
about the duration of his fights my goal
is always to get the job done in the
first round so if i can get the
submission i will squeeze it as hard as
i can to make him tap but if not i'm
ready to go against him for 15 minutes
he then went on the downplay notions
that he thinks he should for sure be
fighting for the title with a win over
dershenko of course that's my goal at
the end of the day but if the title shot
comes okay but i'm not thinking oh if i
win i get a title shot it's something
that is gonna come eventually so when it
comes i'm gonna be ready but i'm not
thinking like chasing it i think it's
gonna happen naturally
watch marcus almeida this friday at 10
pm eastern only on amazon prime video
[Music]
big dreams i got big dreams just like
baby i've been joining forces with the
likes of an agent
play with the fire you get burned all of
my struggles became lessons well learned
i got desires that keep me grounded
that's for sure cause one day we gonna
make it out this earth
[Music]
sean strickland has teamed up with a
star-studded sparring team ahead of his
october 15th bout against jarrod
cannoneer strickland homzachemy of
darren till and chris curtis have been
training together at extreme couture
good luck finding a funner group to
punch each other in the face
no no he have you sparred him
a little bit
he gets a little bit
he gets a little bit
a little bit yeah be nice
understand you're better than you're
better than most you're better than
everybody so just
don't hurt people
okay
so anybody that doesn't have a fight
coming up just float and grab a guy
kamazot chris curtis you guys getting
picked a glitter
what's good i've gone first
two warm-up rounds five rounds sparring
feel free to three if you want all right
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
be a [ __ ] man be smart
and be smart
looking for more original mma content
check out the rest of thick boy youtube
exclusive interviews opinion and fight
analysis is available weekly on the shop
show food truck diaries and fight night
flashbacks subscribe so you don't miss
any of the action